>>> MAN, HOW LONG IS THIS TRAIN
GOING TO TAKE?
>> IT SAYS THE NEXT ONE ARRIVES
IN FORGET ABOUT IT.
I LOVE THIS NEW MAYOR.
>> I'M STARVING.
>> YO, NEWSSTAND GUY, LET ME GET
A SNICKERS AND A BAG OF CHIPS.
>> I'LL GET YOU THE CLOSEST
THING.
AN OH HENRY BAR AND A COPY OF XL
BUTTS.
>> THEY STILL MAKE TO OH HENRY
BARS?
>> NO.
AND WHAT DOES HE WANT?
>> OH, NOTHING FROM YOU.
I'M GOING TO GO BUY A CHURRO.
>> YOU'RE BUYING A WHAT?
>> A CHURRO.
THEY SMELL DELICIOUS, AND THAT'S
SAYING A LOT CONSIDERING I HAVE
ACTIVE COVID.
>> YOU SURE YOU WANT TO BUY AN
UNWRAPPED CHURRO FROM A WOMAN
PUSHING A LAUNDRY CART THAT
SHE'S HOLDING WITH HER BARE
HANDS WITH A STARBUCKS NAPKIN?
>> LOOK, I'M A GROWN DRUNK MAN,
AND I
WANT A CHURRO TO EAT ON THE
CHOO-CHOO RIDE HOME.
>> VERY WELL THEN.
THE DYE IS CAST.
OH, MOLE PERSON, WHY DON'T YOU
TELL THIS GENTLEMAN WHAT HAPPENS
WHEN YOU EAT A CHURRO FROM THE
SUBWAY?
♪♪
♪ SOME DISGUSTING EVENING
YOU WILL BUY A CHURRO
A LOOSE UNPACKAGED CHURRO ♪
♪ AND THEN YOUR
BUTT WILL BLEED ♪
♪ AND SOMEHOW YOU'LL KNOW
AS SOON AS YOU CHEW
THAT AN HOUR BEFORE YOU
A RAT BIT IT TOO.
>> WAIT A SECOND.
MOLE PEOPLE ARE REAL?
>> OF COURSE THEY'RE REAL.
IMAGINE HOW GREAT IT WOULD BE TO
LIVE OFF THE GRID LIKE THAT.
NO MORE ENDLESS TEXTS OR
E-MAILS.
>> WHAT?
♪♪
♪ IF I WERE A MOLE MAN
YABA DEBA DABA DEBA
DABA DEBA DABA DUM ♪
♪ ALL DAY LONG
I'D DRINK A SHOE
OF RUM
IF I WERE A MOLE PERSON ♪
♪ WE'D NEVER HAVE TO WORK
YABA DEBA DABA DEBA
DABA DEBA DABA DEE ♪
♪ I USED TO DRIVE
AN AMAZON VAN
LIVING IN A HOLE
IS SUCH A BETTER PLAN ♪
>> NOW YOU FEAST ON OLD
DISCARDED HANDS!
♪ IF I WERE A
FILTHY MOLE MAN ♪
♪♪
>> OH, WOW.
WAS THAT THE ACTUAL CAST OF
"FIDDLER"?
>> NO.
IT'S JUST THE LUNCH BREAK AT B &
H PHOTO.
>> OH, MY GOD.
THERE'S A WOMAN ON THE TRACKS.
>> IS THAT A GHOST?
>> NO.
SHE WAS JUST FIRED FROM SLEEP NO
MORE.
NOW SHE WANDERS THE TUNNELS.
>> IS SHE OKAY?
>> OH, I'M MORE THAN OKAY.
♪ I AM HIGH ON BATH SALTS
EVERY NIGHT
EVERY DAY ♪
♪ IN MY MIND
YOU THREE ARE DEMONS
IF YOU TOUCH ME
I EAT YOUR FACE ♪
>> WHOA!
THIS IS CRAZY!
>> I KNOW.
IT'S LIKE,
ARE YOU EVEN ALLOWED TO DO SOUTH
PACIFIC ANYMORE?
>> WAIT, CAN YOU TELL ME WHERE
IN THE CITY WE ARE?
>> OH, THE WORST PART.
♪ WE'RE IN MIDTOWN
WHERE THEY SELL
FOOD AT NIGHT ♪
♪ YOU'RE IN MIDTOWN
WHERE THE TRAFFIC LIGHTS ARE
FOR SURE BROKE ♪
♪♪ THE LAND OF FINANCE BOOM.
>> HEY, LOOK.
THE SUBWAY TRAIN'S MAKING ITS
WAY INTO THE STATION, AND IT'S
GOT SOMETHING FOR EVERYONE!
>> DID HE HAVE A LISP EARLIER?
♪ OH LOCAL SUBWAY IS COMING
DOWN THE TRACKS
PLEASE LET IT
STOP FOR ME ♪
♪ OH THE F LOCAL SUBWAY IS
COMING DOWN THE TRACKS ♪
♪ IT'S CALLED THE F
BECAUSE IT'S
EFFING ME ♪
♪ I GOT BITTEN BY A
PIGEON ON MY BIRTHDAY
IN MARCH I GOT
AIRBORNE HPV ♪
♪♪ ONE TIME I SAT DIRECTLY ON A
NEEDLE.
♪ OUR THE MAYOR SAID
HE FIXED IT
BUT I JUST GOT STABBED ♪
>> JULIANNY SAYS HELLO.
>> THIS IS THE F TRAIN, RUNNING
ON THE Q TRACK SKIPPING RANDOM
STATIONS WHEN I FEEL LIKE IT.
>> BUT THIS TRAIN IS EMPTY
EXCEPT FOR ONE MAN IN A TRENCH
COAT.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
I CLEARED EVERYONE OUT.
YOU SEE --
♪ I'M FAPPING ON THE TRAIN
JUST FAPPING ON THE TRAIN
WHAT A GLORIOUS FEELING
I'M NAKED UNDER HERE ♪
>> CONDUCTOR, CAN'T YOU JUST
CLOSE THE DOORS?
>> WELL, I WOULD IF EVAN HANSON
WOULD MOVE HIS BACKPACK.
♪ AND I AM TELLING YOU
I'M NOT MOVING MY BACKPACK ♪
>> THAT'S FROM A DIFFERENT
MUSICAL WITH JENNIFER HUDSON.
>> STOP BULLYING ME!
>> I'VE GOT TO GET THAT GUY ON
BATH SALTS.
>> AND LOOK OUT.
ON THE FLOOR OF THE TRAIN,
THERE'S A PUDDLE OF
UNIDENTIFIABLE ORIGIN.
♪ I AM THE LIQUID
ON THE FLOOR
AM I PEE OR MOUNTAIN DEW ♪
♪ DON'T WORRY
I'M FLOWING ♪
♪ TOWARD THE DOOR
JUST KIDDING.
I'M GOING RIGHT AT YOUR SHOE.
>> STOP RIGHT THERE!
>> EMILY IN PARIS?
>> WE'RE THE GUARDIAN ANGELS.
WE'RE THE PEOPLE THAT REALLY
TAKE CARE OF THIS CITY.
IF YOU'RE LOOKING FOR A FIGHT,
YOU GOT TO GO THROUGH US.
>> OH, REALLY?
I'M POSSIBLY THE REAL
JESUS CHRIST.
WEARING MY FAMOUS NEW YORK
ISLANDERS BEARD.
AND IF YOU WANT THIS SUBWAY,
YOU'LL HAVE TO KILL ME AGAIN
FIRST.
>> OH, MY GOD.
IT'S ALL HAPPENING!
>> JUST AS THE ORACLE PREDICTED.
♪ JESUS CHRIST
DOESN'T TRACK WITH
WHAT WE KNOW SO FAR ♪
♪ JESUS CHRIST
WEARING CROCS
WHY DOES SHE HAVE
A SPIDER IN A BOX ♪
♪ JESUS CHRIST
REALLY DRUNK
SHE BOUGHT STATION
CHURROS FOR EVERYONE ♪
>> IT'S A MIRACLE!
♪ JESUS CHRIST
JESUS CHRIST
JESUS CHRIST ♪